I was born in Morocco born and raised in
Morocco then I moved to to France and
now to America well it's interesting
because so then you would have do you
have a Moroccan Passport yeah I also
have a Moroccan Passport
I don't use it to be honest with you I
mean don't get me wrong I'm proud of my
roots and my home country but now it's
not a good idea to show up in the US
with a big green passport that has gold
Arabic letters and tell them I'm a
comedian
it's funny you know funny you know I
have started traveling a lot with the
show and and tried to visit different
countries I've never been to Morocco
what would you recommend I would love to
take you tomorrow go you would take me
should I take you tomorrow yeah okay so
tell us what kind of things would we do
in Morocco first thing I would take you
to is a hmmm okay what's that huh I have
to know what that is before it's a can
of the steam room with no steam we're at
a point of a steam room with no steam it
just get really hot you sit there and
then there's a man those place no and
you know I need to go to Morocco oh yeah
I get you now we called the Port
Authority and you get naked and not
really I mean just all the way naked no
just a little towel I'll be with you no
worries I'll be with you naked and the
towel you go all the way naked or do you
go no just how I go towel you go towel
he will go towel okay I got nothing to
hide and the big guy comes I don't know
if it's gonna go towel this other guy
wait is he naked to this I don't know
he's working there okay and he's gonna
rub scrub your body and exfoliate all
the bacon and cheeseburgers and all the
things
from you and you're gonna feel real good
wait and so this guy just comes into the
room and it holy eighths you yeah is it
a pleasurable experience there's a
painful after there's a happy ending its
immense t what do you mean is that happy
how happy and thing is a minty and you
relax and you listen you know two good
Moroccan music and working pastries but
I call that a happy ending
you're gonna get some very angry
customers don't worry you get the happy
ending later what that is I'm gonna take
you they're gonna really I really want
to take you is there they have all the
what do they have that we have to like
for example I'm always curious when a
country has they have everything I mean
this is so American of you you want me
to take you to Starbucks in Morocco okay
I'll take you to Starbucks and Zara and
I don't know coffee bean right I'm
always curious to how many countries now
have uber like you go to a country and
they and you think they're not gonna
have a burr and then they have uber
you know what's crazy with uber now they
call you on your phone they called you
on your cell phone and go where are you
what do you mean where are you I'm in my
apartment waiting for you and they're
like oh I'm on my way I know that's the
whole point of there and then you track
them do you track those guys on you
don't you know cars you cannot do this
with a real car the slide the complete
turn and all the other cars are like
this what should we do
well I really would love to go with you
I seriously would it's a it's all set
we put out an D we're going on all right
go with this guy they're all coming
you